i love your husband and you um your love
story is it true you got married during
the pandemic yes we did congratulations
[Applause]
and you guys work together yes what's it
like to collaborate with a husband
husband core yes husband court it's um
it's
so great um it's so complicated it's
it's like
extreme highs and extreme you know
complications it's like it's a really
hard thing to navigate but um but we man
we've been together for
11 years oh my god yeah yeah we just and
you work together multiple times many
times over yeah
so whatever the complexities are you
seem to figure out how to navigate that
yeah we just muscle our way through it
and um and i think yeah the yeah the
emergency was just like a joke that
honestly just went too far like that was
it was yeah so
wait how did you dress up on your
wedding day uh actually i straight up
was wearing um something like this and
what kind of dress did you wear okay so
we got married on a whim literally
decided at around 5 p.m got married at 8
30.
um
i wore so jeff got really into tie-dying
during the quarantine so um i decided
that jeff and i were going to wear
tie-dye pajamas that he had made for us
so we were tie-dye pajamas and then i
had my little rosemary crown and i
um i made like a love altar in the
backyard of all of our like
love objects like um it was very witch
core but it happened well it sounds so
lovely i'm so glad i asked okay now
people you know your character on parks
and rack was like super dry
yeah um so um i would love to play a
game with you okay okay it's called on
the sunny side
and apparently
it's got a western theme all of a sudden
well come on down to the sunny side come
on down it's time to crack some eggs oh
yeah
western core that's right um okay aubry
i want to give you some scenarios about
the holidays that are less than ideal
and your challenge is to look on the
sunny side of things okay okay
you look for your crush underneath the
mistletoe but you might not see them and
you're looking around but on the sunny
side there's a there's a beautiful woman
that's right there and you and you just
thought i don't know let me do something
crazy
and just
try something else
i mean i think every girl that has
crushes on you out there everywhere just
got a little bit of hope fantastic
that's a real on the sunny side moment
okay new year's eve is right around the
corner and we all make resolutions that
will break in the second week of january
but on the sunny side
we're all gonna die so nothing matters
thank you i love it
you're the only one who showed up to the
ugly sweater party wearing the ugly
sweater
and on the sunny side everybody
thinks it's sweater core and you just
started a trend exactly
the yule log is wet and won't light
but on the sunny side
there's a fire problem in the area and
it's just it's better this way
okay you're gonna pick out the perfect
christmas tree but there's only one
small
bare one left
but on the sunny side but on the sunny
day you can plant it in your little
garden and then it can be your tree
every year and you just water it and you
can just go that's my little freak tree
and i like it
aubry plaza
you are everything core
you are everything core
[Applause]
legend of the christmas switch is on
sale
[Music]
you